what do you think right now is the
fastest way to get to your first
$100,000 by not liking the word to
actually answer you literally the
fastest way to get there is attention is
the number one asset hi nice to meet you
what's the one thing that if you had
learned it at 25 it would have
accelerated your success trajectory so
much more that cander was a good thing
not a bad thing and I didn't really know
what the word cander meant at the time
but when I look back at my career at
this point it's very clear to me that
that is the you know that that was the
Kryptonite that things were going super
well and things went well and things are
well but the one place where I could
have really taken it to the next level
would have been when I look back at my
career all of the professional
relationships that could be better today
and I really believe in relationships
were predominantly employees
occasionally partners and vendors where
I wasn't capable of delivering bad news
out of actually loving them and liking
them and that then led to muckery
resentment on my end sloppy exits and
firings or partnership breakups and so
over the last three four years I think
I've been able to up my cander game
dramatically by reframing it as kind
cander and that's really worked for me
I'm still probably a five out of 10
which is not really great but boy going
from a 1 out of 10 or a two out of 10 to
a five or six out of 10 has been a
Monster jump and I feel the effects and
that is definitely the black and white
answer to if I could do it at 25
differently what's the lack of cander
you had at 25 and then now if someone is
underperforming at your company what
kind of cander do you have with them I'm
just able to have the conversation you
know hey Johnny can I get 15 minutes
with you Hey listen brother I love you
you're a good dude you do a lot of
things right but this and this that
you're not doing well it's so
detrimental that it might lead to us not
being able to work together so can we
work on it and here's how I can help and
here's how you can help that combo just
didn't happen before you know it would
come out and like I'd walk by Johnny and
be like hey Johnny like you know get
your game up brother haha like you know
I would do these little things and ra if
I was close to you I would Raz you like
I would try to communicate through like
a joke or a Raz that was heavily you
know dipped in honey and sugar so it
wouldn't hurt I was just being around
the bush and so now it's like what does
it look like even having the combo just
having it and the reason I'm 5 out of 10
is even when I'm having them now I got
to really like get there to like be like
no no you got to shoot it straight cuz
it's in me to be around the bush in that
scenario and I'm really really
practicing on going right at it and it's
really been helpful do you believe in
hire slowly fire quickly or do you give
people more shots I'm the reverse
actually I'm a big believer in hiring
fast I think people overthink it it's a
guessing game like resumés are loaded
with
people's I don't think I've ever checked
check the reference check it's not
practical it's not common sense of
course you're going to put the three
people that either most believe in you
or love you Andor you prep them to be
like hey get my back um so I think
you're making an intuitive guess I think
you're making a logical guess to the
best of your ability based on what you
know about your organization and the
series of questions you asked I'm a big
fan of hiring fast meaning I don't think
you should just hire everyone but if you
feel it you don't need to go through too
many more rounds it all depends on how
much you trust your intuition and
pattern recog
I think once you have someone in your
organization you now know the truth
hiring is guessing firing is knowing to
me it's higher fast fire faster and I'll
explain that in a minute that doesn't
mean like be mean and fire it means put
in the work quickly if you can recognize
something's not working and if it
doesn't work after six months to a year
like you got to go and make that move
and make sure you don't surprise the
person that's what I've had to work on
and then my big one is promote fastest
which is like if you know you have a
superstar don't wait well you told them
you're going to revisit their salary in
two years if you know somebody's
remarkable in four months and you can
afford it consider showing them that you
want to be with them long term by
promoting a little bit faster how do you
spot those superstars on your team it
all depends on who you are as a boss for
me I'm so in the dirt like I'm in my
business so for me I don't know I just
see it like if you're doing your craft
you see it plus for me I came up the
game in a way where I've done all the
jobs that people are doing so I know how
to judge it which is huge in the wine
and liquor store business and the same
in this marketing agency like it's just
easy for me to see it because I've done
it I think one there's that two if
you're in an ivory Tower if you've got a
global organization and you can't see
everybody and maybe you aren't even
someone who's done all the crafts you
came up to CFO ranks or something else
that's where you need to rely on people
you trust I always tell leaders judge
the judgers I think too many leaders
blindly take the feedback of their
direct reports without realizing
sometimes their direct reports are
undermining people underneath them cuz
they themselves don't want to lose their
spot but if you can judge the judgers
and have a good feel on that you can
figure out who you need to trust and
those people's words should carry a lot
of weight even as in it as I am there
are 30 people in bayner X Out of 2000
whose words carry a lot of weight and
have the capacity and the ability to
change my mind on someone I'll double
click into it after they're like I'm
like does Sally stink and they can tell
a masking if Sally I think Sally stinks
and then if two of them are like no no
Sally's remarkable I'm like huh and then
I'll double click I'll spend more time
in Sally I'll watch Sally's work more
it's pretty cool getting from one to 100
employees is very different from 100 to
a th000 a th000 to 2,000 what has had to
shift about you to get to that growth
well a couple things you have to let go
you know I hired everybody in the first
like there wasn't a single person we
hired that I didn't interview in the
first 100 I don't think I've interviewed
anybody in the last 500 outside of two
or three or four SE Suite direct reports
so you've got to rely on the good work
at 100 to get you to 1,000 meaning too
many people listening are looking to
flip their business so let's make this
work for everyone if you're flipping
your business you're playing a different
game you're trying to maximize profit
you don't care what the company looks
like in 20 years if you're going more
family business or Evergreen like I am
everything's about the first 100
employees the reason I had to hire
everyone is cuz I knew that I needed 39
of those 100 to get me to a th000 back
to the prior question of who carries
weight with me right I needed them to
know my religion meaning like do I most
believe in you know and all those things
and that's why we've been able to get
here it's the foundation of that first
100 the fact that we have 20 30 40 50
from that first 100 or even 10 but 50
from the first 200 50 300 that's the
game and so you know I think that's the
point can you be remarkable in your
first 100 which means you're over
spending your time on HR you know you're
really building a family I know a lot of
people look to you to learn how to make
money online and build these business
businesses what do you think right now
is the fastest way to get to your first
$100,000 by not liking the word
fast I'm really scared of that word I
think fast is dangerous and I think it's
a big part of my content it's why I talk
about patience it's why I talk about
self-awareness the reality is to
actually answer you literally the
fastest way to get there is through
self-awareness understanding what you're
actually good at you know you know like
what are you good at you might be good
at sales you might be good at operations
you might be good at knowing everything
about the Marvel Universe and that is
actually your gateway to get there
fastest cuz it's through content or
flipping stuff on eBay and stuff of that
nature so I think people try to chase
Trends real estate crypto cannabis AI
they're just constantly looking at these
Trends because they see them as things
that will get them there fast and I
actually think that those are the things
that are most guaranteed to not get you
there so I think if we can get the word
word fastest out of everyone's mouth
especially under 30 and get the word
happiest and most likely in there so ask
that question again by replacing fastest
with happiest and most likely go ahead
let's do that what do you think is the
most likely way to get to $100,000 in
the happiest way is like what is the
question I'm most passionate about you
know and then that answer becomes super
unique you know of of course there's
macro things if you like selling
understanding e-commerce and social
media is going to really help obviously
if you really know how to use Shopify
and you really know how to make Tik toks
and Instagram and YouTube shorts there's
a real path to 100,000 selling almost
anything this is why I'm big on passions
and hobbies I believe almost every
passion hobby I always use Dustin and
his BMX passion or me and wrestling or
the New York Jets or hip-hop music or
drawing or meditation or eating clean
and healthy like there's so many ways to
get to 100,000 by being a Creator by
sharing in Revenue with the platforms by
selling T-shirts about what you do about
selling tickets to a live event like in
two years working hard making content
and I mean really making content
multiple posts a day across all the
platforms around your favorite Passion
Wine I did that um in 2006 when it was
hard and it can be very narrow I mean I
really do believe in two or three years
you can make $100,000 a year just
talking about Ohio State football
because your podcast and your content is
a top 10 because you really knew it and
loved it and you were good at it and so
I always push people towards that
because it will be the happiest way if
you're in love with snow globes making
$100,000 a year selling snow globes
versus making $130,000 a year being a
real estate agent the path to that in
the same three-year window was extremely
joyful in snow globe land and probably
stressful in real estate land but your
friends told you that's the way you can
make a 100,000 because real estate is a
really good business right and so I
think about this a lot and I think the
word fastest is the danger because I
think fastest leads us to doing things
we don't love it leads us to doing
things cuz we love the idea of making
money to do the things we love think
about that you have somebody in that
scenario who wants to be a real estate
agent so she can afford a trip to the
National snow globe conference and
Convention and do it bougie she's tired
driving for 9 hours to it and staying at
the Holiday Inn she wants to fly first
class and stay at the Four Seasons at
the national snow globe convention and
that is one of the reasons that she
decided to be a real estate agent versus
understanding what I'm saying which is
start the snow globe podcast make tons
of snow globe content realize that
there's millions of people that collect
snow globes start an affiliate eBay
business make t-shirts get sponsors from
the top 10 snow globe companies by
emailing them into telling them a year
in that you actually have an audience
these are things that excite me more
what do you see as the Trends on social
media right now the biggest
opportunities there are out there by
becoming a better practitioner and
here's what I mean by that the days of
just posting aimlessly a video or
picture are getting harder to win
because everyone's doing it and it's
supply and demand so now understanding
the science behind the art what's the
thumbnail look like what's your copy
look like what time do you post how does
Tik Tok work differently than Instagram
I'm working on a new book called day
trading attention and it goes very deep
into this it's a 301 to my book that
really helped a lot of people in so show
called jab jab jab right hook I would
call this like an PhD to that High
School course and I'm excited about it
and what it really opened my eyes to
which was in my conscious and
subconscious but as I'm going through
this six-month period working with ROV
who's helping me write it it's just so
clear how hard it is to be great at
Social in 2024 and to be great you've
got to really know your craft you got to
be better and so the trend is being
better like really understanding should
you post a real or should post a
carousel posted something the other day
and got immediate feedback that it was
working from somebody live and sat this
Saturday so last Friday or Thursday I
posted a post that said hey have you
been noticing that I on Instagram I'm
posting a two poost Carousel where the
first one is a meme and the second one
is the video clip that you were
accustomed to seeing me just post I'm
not doing that for my health I'm doing
that because I've observed that it's
working you should consider this too
sure enough I think the real Tarzan that
influencer I saw him on Saturday in Utah
at a conference and he came up to me
he's like bro you're [__] genius
thank you like I the first post I did
with that tactic I did a lot better than
I've been doing last month thank you and
that's the ultimate for me when I do
content that someone else takes it and
runs and that's why I'm doing this
podcast I'm hoping someone becomes the
snow globe podcaster and emails me and
for years that that thank you card
whether in DM email or in person is like
the most delicious feeling for me
professionally right now so that's why I
continue to do this work anyway
nonetheless I think the biggest tactic
is to actually realize there's science
there's strategy and this isn't just
being pretty or funny or like just
gimmicky anymore like you've got to get
great at it and so we call it at vorx
sock strategic organic content MH
strategic why I want everybody right now
to ask themselves why they posted the
last or the next post and most of it is
grounded in their subconscious that
something like this used to work and I
want it to work in the algorithm that's
not good enough anymore and this whole
philosophy is grounded in something we
call pack platforms and culture so
really understanding the platforms how
YouTube shorts works but then also
understanding culture like why are
corduroy hats in why did sexy red work
you know why why why why why why is
everyone infatuated with Taylor Swift
and Kelsey right it's not just two
celebrities getting together it's a
little bit of like that All-American
kind of like you know football player
and the cheerleader pop you know what I
mean like understanding the deeper
meaning and understanding what that
means to you and understanding is there
anything for you to do about it that's
what I spend my time on I had never
heard of Kelsey until last week correct
and so the question becomes like what is
that like you know is that true love is
that pop culture your strategy is that
you know for me what that learning is
for everyone is forget about the gossip
of it all cuz that always gets buckery
and I always I always feel bad for you
know people that have a relationship in
the public eye because that's incredibly
challenging whether they choose to do it
or not I still have a lot of empathy
towards that what I think is let's take
that down to somebody who's a mechanic
right now listening the [__] does Taylor
Swift and Kelsey have to do with me
here's what it has to do with you Donnie
the mechanic what you just said this
morning I see how many people now follow
Kelsey that did a week ago those are
people that didn't know who that was on
the flip side for Taylor there's a lot
of football fans who now know her a
little more cuz she had more awareness
right well for Donnie the mechanic that
might mean in his local Town in Detroit
he may want to go do a
collaboration with a Thai
restaurant where maybe they do something
silly together where they cook a meal at
the auto shop and in return he gives
everyone a free meal at that restaurant
if they use a tuneup with him for a
month because the bigger thing in the
Kelsey Taylor Swift thing from a small
business standpoint was
cross-pollinating audiences that have no
crossover leads to more
business I know what I just did there
for 3 minutes is not how most people
think I also know that that's why I've
had professional business marketing
success it's what I try to bring as a
value prop to the audience that excites
me that's a different level of thinking
and that's what I'm trying to get the
world into thinking more strategically
than just throwing against the wall and
see what sticks nothing about my career
is by accident of course there's
Serendipity but I think a lot and I act
on thoughts a lot and I test and try a
lot many of the things I do don't show
up in a podcast like this there were
many meme SL video two post Carousel
efforts that me and the team do all the
time they don't all work but
what's exciting is I don't have fear in
trying and I think most people listening
get caught in the same routines and have
too much fear of trying new things
because they're scared of micro losing
and what I'm trying to do is get people
in business in entrepreneurship and most
of all in life to stop fearing as much
because too many are living their entire
lives on the currency of fear what do
you think is the worst strategic
decision that you've made obviously
you've made a lot of of good ones to
stay relevant for so many years there's
so many I didn't invest in Uber twice
when it was my best bud and like it was
because I was a little cash strapped and
I valued short-term cash over long-term
opportunity that probably cost me
anywhere between 250 600 million which
is more money than I have right now so
that was huge when Steven Ross bought a
piece of Vayner X he offered me a piece
of the Dolphins instead of money I
emotionally said no because I love the
Jets too much that was obnoxiously bad
um I switched from YouTube to something
called vidler early in my career because
I like the tagging system of vidler that
probably left me not being able to build
10 times bigger audience on YouTube I
was there in
2006 before anybody was there and I
really really missed that moment I was
right and then I was wrong um I mean I
could literally give you another hundred
examples of these are big ones these are
Big so I'm on vac ation just thinking
cuz that's what I do when I'm laying in
the sun doing nothing I can't help it
and I'm like you know what [__]
Netflix is going to be huge so I never
buy stock so like it was like even weird
for me to reach out to like my financial
adviser I'm like I want to buy stock
because usually if I have stock it's
because I invested in the company early
and called my investment team and said I
you know I'd like to put some of my cash
into Netflix stock as we're talking
through the like we're kind of in the
middle details the Wi-Fi was bad and it
hung up
I call back and it doesn't work you know
beep beep beep like I don't have this
I'm trying to walk around for a minute
or two and I can't get the service I'm
like you know what [__] it I'll I'll you
know I got back I walked all the way
back to my seat texted my team and said
we'll get to this when I get back from
vacation never do it I mean the number I
said I wanted to put I mean seven Hefty
seven figures of return I was that right
and that
early I've got too many and anybody I
think who's Fair ly successful in
business has too many too because it was
all those decisions that got them there
which means there was a lot of other
decisions they either got horribly wrong
or missed out on opportunity not to
mention the way I actually think about
life is it's the meetings and
opportunities that you don't even know
that you missed last night there was a
dinner with a bunch of leaders of
agencies that at the last minute for
family reasons I canceled that could
have been the meeting that changed the
course of my career so I just listed
four or five good ones I promise you the
10 top biggest mistakes I've ever made
were things I didn't show up for or
didn't say yes to that would have led to
remarkable opportunity that I have no
idea even happened I think once you get
to that place mentally and realize
you're constantly making mistakes and
you're okay with it it actually
liberates you to enjoy this process more
and I think too many people struggle
with that what's on the flip side what's
been your most profitable investment I
mean Facebook and Twitter as Investments
were remarkable
but the biggest Investments I'll ever
have is the ones I put my own time and
effort into bner X and things of that
nature but there's been many great
Investments I've made in my portfolio
and they all take on to give you a
little bit more value for the audience
let me tell you what I've now realize 25
years in that I look for I have to love
the idea and the person and every time
I've either loved just the idea or just
the person and made a investment I've
lost so I think if you're doing early
stage investing in someone's company or
an internet company or even like a local
Baker like I'm starting to think about
investing in small businesses more cuz
I'm starting to notice what works and so
like if I go look at a young lady or a
young man who has like a bakery or like
a tea shop or like a healthy clean food
store or a t-shirt shop or bike shop I'm
starting to think more about like could
this be the next Starbucks could this be
the next Toys R Us us when I look for
that I know now that I'm looking for I
like idea and the person and I've made
too many mistakes with picking only one
so I have to be two for two now and uh
that's what I recommend everybody who's
looking if somebody's asking you to
invest and you've got a couple dollars
to invest in something even if it's like
a local dentist who wants to open up
another office like believe in dentistry
and believe in Ronnie or Sarah the
dentist my sister's a dentist if you
want to invest I love it I love that I
use that
analogy how do you think about growing
your money are you allocating certain
percentages to certain things or yeah as
you know recently last 5 years I've
gotten to a place where I have a money
management team and they're pushing me
I'm still way too entrepreneurial I'm
not maximizing my money I would still
rather Gamble and it's really not
gambling I'd rather I'm just saying that
because I want everybody to understand
what I'm actually doing I'd rather
entrepreneur than invest I'd rather lose
my money going for a home run than make
7% on my money and have it sit there and
that's because I'm trying to maximize
Joy not money I'm going to leave more
than enough money for my grandchildren
let alone my children right so I'm not
here trying to maximize my money I'm
trying to maximize my joy I've worked
really hard for a really long time and
I've really done right by my dad and my
brother and many others and you know at
this point in my life I'd like to enjoy
the process of making or losing money as
much as possible and so I don't think my
advice is right for everyone but I think
it's right for a lot of people and I've
done that my whole life by the way some
of my best investments Facebook Twitter
things of that nature I didn't have a
lot of money I wanted to make money
through joy and it was fun to bet on the
future that I saw and it worked out and
so I think um you know even if you have
$5,000 in
savings if you'd rather buy a 100 shares
of your favorite Company's stock because
you rock their clothes or use their
video games or whatever it is that's a
good debate are you better off to enjoy
it than to have a guaranteed return in a
for
401K right something worth debating just
got to know yourself and know what
you're trying to maximize for if you're
trying to maximize for money creation
then you should let professional money
managers handle it on maximizing Joy how
do you make sure that you're not
straying away from the things that give
you Joy because I'm sure as you're
scaling it's easy when HR gets involved
and you have so many employees to lose
sight of the things that give you Joy
just because you're running a larger
operation so how do you make sure that
doesn't happen by hiring people to do
the things that you don't love so what
do you absolutely love in your business
that you would never hire out well at
the scale we're at now you hire but you
still do it so for example the things I
love is HR I love my people so even
though we have a full pet team people
experience and talent we wanted to
Rebrand it once I realized people didn't
like HR even though we have a huge team
I still allocate a lot of time but I get
to be the cherry on top not the Sunday
you understand it's not a requirement
it's a it's a joy to have um I love
selling so even though kayn our chief
business officer and the new business
team is doing a remarkable job this year
and this is the best year that that team
has ever had I still join a ton of them
because I like selling our company I
like being in the big meetings where
there's a Crossroads in the relationship
so even though Nick and Lisa Buckley and
all these head of Partnerships and
account are remarkable what they do I
like joining the occasional meetings
that really matter not because I don't
trust them because I enjoy being a part
of them but at first I'll give you a
different example we hired a lawyer and
we hired him fast Mark yudkin when we
couldn't afford it because there was no
joy or knowledge or understanding of
anything legal on my end and I did not
want to even begin to learn it right we
we hired um AJ my brother and my dad
have always handled the finances in
essence we the CFO and we hired a CFO
pretty early in our journey um even
though AJ liked it um and so like if AJ
didn't like being a CFO and handling the
books we would have hired somebody to do
finances day one so those are examples
of how you I think about it and how I
think it would help people to maximize
Joy hire for things you don't like to do
and even though you hire for things you
like to do spend more time on that
because you're doubling up on sale this
company has a high happiness ratio for
how big it is and always grows in
Topline Revenue it's because I'm
doubling down on HR and new
business where does the revenue come
from for the business uh clients you
know the Pepsis the Chase Banks the
crafts the Fanatics the Alaska Airlines
are clients so is the majority of the
revenue from direct from the clients for
the 100% of the revenue 100% of the
revenue of VOR X is Client Services 100%
this was the the client service engine
that I built in my world so yeah that's
the business we're like you know an
advertising holding company there's bner
Commerce and even Noam which is Madison
AV spell backwards that's our production
company there's bner 3 which is like our
Consulting Innovation agency there's the
Sasha group named after my dad for small
businesses to do what we do at Vayner
media Vayner media there's Gallery Media
Group which is our publishing arm that
houses 137 p.m. in pure wow um you know
there's tingly Lane trading which is a
barter agency that takes physical goods
from companies and converts it into
media for them so we're we're like a wpp
an Omnicom a publist these are publicly
traded companies that are marketing
service businesses that's the business
we earlier you were talking about the
home runs what are the home runs that
you're going after right now in general
in the macro mhm vriends my vriends
journey which is my intellectual
property that is kind of like a mix
between Pokemon and Sesame Street both
in nft form trading card form animation
form collectible toys form that is a
very big project a very big home run
that's a grand slam if I pull that off
which I intend on you know you're
talking about a very big deal the Hannah
barbaras the Disney the Pokemons the
Hello Kitties the Transformers the Power
Rangers the Harry Potters these
intellectual properties are major
business and so I'm really enjoying that
especially cuz the Sesame Street part is
the purpose you know there's a purpose
in me wanting to make gratitude gorilla
something kids want to put on their
backpack it's called teaching the world
to love gratitude and once you have
gratitude you don't have as much
jealousy and envy because you're
grateful for what you have versus
worried about what everybody else has
and so that's the biggest home run I
think the other biggest home run or
grand slam I'm working on is how do I
make Gary ve as big as popular as
possible with the intent of reframing
how to be an entrepreneur or be what the
success if we can reframe success we can
reframe everything even notice how I
jumped in on that fastest question you
know if you can if you can do it
meaningfully if you can do it with joy I
don't know why people would compromise
being happy for money it's literally
people think money makes you happy and
we know and everybody knows people that
have money that are not happy and yet we
give up happiness every day in the
pursuit of money thinking that will buy
it for us to me it's why don't we fight
for figuring out what makes you happy
and then live within the means of what
you make cuz there's unlimited people on
Earth who make less than $60,000 a year
who are very happy yet we're not very
good at telling that story do you think
before you had money you thought also
that money would make you happy no
because I was always fighting for this
is why I'm so passionate about this I
was pumped at 40,000 a year because I
was doing what I loved I was trying to I
was helping my dad build a business for
him I was going to garage sales on the
weekend cuz I wasn't getting paid much
to buy [__] you know and flip it I was
watching the Jets and I was going on
dates and I was living within my means I
didn't have the capacity to take a
private flight I didn't have the
capacity to own an expensive car I
didn't have the capacity to have bougie
things like a driver housek keeper
things of that nature but that was that
that had no impact on 23 25 27 29 31y
old Gary I didn't aspire to have those
things I aspire to have the happiness I
had and I fight for that when have you
found felt in The Last 5 Years furthest
away from being happy personally like
there's always trials and tribulations
and I don't really go too too too much
in my personal life but I think all of
us go through different challenges of
things in our personal life and by the
way one of the reasons I think I'm
happiest is cu I keep my personal life
private I really recommend that for
people as all of us start to live public
lives you don't have to be Charlie
demilio or Logan Paul to have your life
public many of us are posting our
boyfriend and girlfriend or or
significant other we're posting real
life stuff about this I promise you you
if you give the world your private life
they take it so hey that's something
worth considering for everybody's
listening no matter even if you don't
aspire to be Taylor Swift like you give
your you give your outer c not not your
family and friends like your Outer
Circle you give them permission to be in
your relationship they own your
relationship something worth thinking
about anyway to answer you
professionally I had a really tough day
it was I don't know if it was the
furthest from happiness but it was a
real gut punch and we started with this
the day I realized my cander made me
wrong in a thousand relationships that I
had in my mind not them because in my
20s and 30s when I would fire someone
after them being there for two years and
they sucked no [__] they stunk the
whole time but I never said anything and
I didn't manage them you know I didn't
make it better I just let it sit and I
thought I was doing them a favor right
but what I was doing was I was in
creating entitlement and I was in
creating resentment was creating
entitlement and resentment entitlement
on their end resentment on my end and
that I would fire them and they would be
shocked and mad and [__] you Gary at the
most extreme because usually I was like
so close with them that they would feel
comfortable doing that especially in the
liquor store you know stock guys don't
give a [__] um and all the kids I hired
early on at bner kids I was mad at them
I was like how do these people not see
it are you [__] kidding me I've been
doing charity for the last two years
five six years ago when I had that
moment that come to Jesus moment like
really that day or two or week that it
was clear on my in the front of my head
not in the back and I would look myself
in the mirror or I would sit and take a
shower or I'd be on a flight and think
about it or while I was dreaming and
sleeping about it that week when I was
reconciling wait a minute it's been me
my inability to tell the truth about how
I feel when I'm upset and even when I'm
happy like one of the things I'm
thinking a lot about now is I don't
smell the roses for myself and that
leads to my management style I'm I'm
better at being like good job like I
sprinkle it more than I do bad job but
it's not like it's over overtly in me I
don't communicate it through words I
communicate it through actions and Vibe
when that happened to me that was a low
point of my professional career that
means that I had to reconcile that you
know all of us would like to think we're
good and perfect you know what I mean
and we know we're not but when you don't
see it when you don't see that you're
spoiled like when you don't see it when
you're complaining with your friends but
your friends all know that your parents
are paying your rent and you're still
complaining they don't have that they're
not looking at you with sympathy they're
looking at you with judgment to your
delusion of your entitlement everyone's
looking through the lens of themselves
when they look at you and even though
that person might be right just cuz your
parents are paying rent doesn't mean
your life's awesome but it's still
something we need to like talk about
which is here's a good question for
everybody what is a flaw that you have
that you can't see right now and that's
something I've spent you know what kind
of really caught me was that something I
spent a lot of time on me saying this
out loud is something I've done to
myself which is why over my 47 years on
Earth starting at 101 12 13 when [__]
like that started hitting my radar which
is weird which is why I cruised through
high school I was so self-aware I
struggled with no peer pressure anytime
somebody picked on me or was mean to me
and growing up in the 80s and 90s in New
Jersey that happened every day kids I
felt bad for them I was like I wonder if
their parents I wonder like I would
paint pictures I'd be like oh this
person is picking on me but like maybe
their dad's an alcoholic like I would do
that at like 15 and by the way in the
80s and 90s the world wasn't as aware
but I was anyway that all led me to be
pretty self-aware and like work on [__]
but this [__] cander boy was that
hiding that [__] was cander you
[__] you really hid somewhere in
I don't know where the [__] you were
under my appendix up my [__] I don't
know where the [__] you were but you
were [__] hiding and I couldn't find
you and the day I found it was a low
point point because it made me have to
rewind 25 years and think through a lot
of things and change my perspective I
love that the self-awareness is so
important we all need it and and I'm
doing things right now that I can't see
and I'm excited to challenge myself and
I challenge everyone to do it because
you will get much happier because let me
say this and this will help a lot of
people this is something I've said in
the past and I've got a lot of feedback
from this quote so I'm hoping this helps
someone that's never heard it before the
only people you're tricking are the
people you don't want to trick you're
not tricking winners
you're tricking other people that are
losing with your so if you know you're
doing something wrong or you're doing
something
poorly you might think you're tricking
people you're not the most self-aware
and emotionally intelligent people
around you they may not say something to
you for example I might be your best
friend in my 20s and 30s I would have
never said anything but I knew I knew
what my friends were doing wrong or what
they sucked at I just didn't have the
stomach to tell them and I promise you
your most self-aware loving people
around you your mom your dad your best
friend your spouse your partner they're
not telling you either but they know so
you're not tricking them so you might as
well figure out what the [__] you want
to do with that that's an amazing way to
end so the we have a closing tradition
podcast is called Erica taught me but
today is all about Gary taught me so
what do you want people to walk away
saying Gary taught me this Gary taught
me to love myself more and accept my
shortcomings and say them out loud and
start to work on them thank you so much
thank you
yay
[Music]
oh